well it wasn't the precise moments the
the the the the way in which I came to
this realization what was that um I was
I was trying to to evade a theorem which
had been proved about this way of
breaking symmetries in in in in particle
physics which implied that there would
be would exist massless particles of no
without spin and this this theorem made
the this kind of theory unacceptable the
course such particles were not not known
and they the the theory which in which
these occurred had been formulated for
years early earlier by Yahiro Nambu who
got a share of the 2008 prize and
Geoffrey Goldstone and it was really for
me a matter of realizing that the
theorem has proved had a flaw in it the
word there were certain mathematical
axioms which you need to prove any kind
of theorem which certain kinds of of
field theory of fields didn't obey and
the prime example of the kind of field
which didn't obey these axioms was
Maxwell's electromagnetic fields as as
it occurs in quantum electrodynamics
quantum electrodynamics is a theory
which doesn't involve this phenomenon of
symmetry breaking but once it was clear
that there were fields of the maximal
type which which didn't obey the the
axioms then the way was opened to
introducing these fields of this type in
to the theory kind of theory which Nambu
which started of of symmetry breaking
and that's essentially what what
happened to me over a weekend during
which I gradually realized that I knew
two things which had to be brought
together it was related to the fact that
I had read papers not long before by
Julian Schwinger who was one of the
people who shared the quantum
electrodynamics prize and that was 65 I
think and he had a way of formulating
that theory which was a little bit
different from what most people
preferred and it it resulted in some
equations which were explicitly
violating apparently violating the rules
of Einstein relativity theory but the
physics was not affected by this it was
just a peculiarity of the formal
mathematics and so it was it was my
recollection of of equations written by
Julian Schwinger which which made me see
that this was what had to be done but it
was a process which wasn't sudden that
it was a during the weekend and I had to
go back to my office on the Monday and
check that I hadn't made hadn't made a
mistake about this